I guess my problem with the way that the
entire pandemic was communicated there
were people who were incredibly notable
experts in their field with glowing
reputations who profit a different View
and it doesn't matter your reputation
your title none of that in science none
of that matters unless by their
reputation they have access to
large-scale studies that they are
reporting to you
okay but not be not the lone person who
says I have this degree and I hail from
this this story institution and I'm
telling you that all those people are
wrong that is the sure sign that you
should not pay attention to them
okay this this spills over this spills
over into our UFO hearings here in the
United States uh they're people
testifying that they have alien
stockpiled in the back room and they're
they're the the introduction of them
there there's a kernel or there's a this
and they they're they're a credible
Witness
no such thing as a credible witness in
science are you human that's all we care
about uh then I will not count York I
will not
um trust in your account more than
someone else's what I will trust in is
the data brought to you by means that do
not flow through the biophysiology of
human senses and so yeah I don't care
what the pedigree is and that's a
problem yes it's a complete problem so
Neil I suppose the question would be in
that situation and I'm not talking about
covet specifically but if you look at
the history of Science and you'll know
this way better than I do of course it
has there not been a historical role for
people who are outliers who come in and
go I've got this crazy idea that perhaps
people dismiss initially but later turns
out to have actually been correct yeah
the Press loves talking about those
people and yes they exist they're rare
but they exist what you don't hear about
are the tens of thousands of other
people who had crazy ideas who were just
crazy
there are no books about them overcoming
the resistance of the establishment
nobody writes about them because they
were just Plum wrong okay so the the one
person who is right against an
establishment is one and I would say ten
thousand
and that's not enough to put all your
your your your your your your your piggy
bank on the YouTube video of that one
person thinking they're the one in the
ten thousand completely agreed so I
guess the next question logically is
what do we do with those people who to
use your terminology a plum wrong
because we saw during the pandemic these
people were demonetized they had their
channels canceled they were Shadow
banned and all of this kind of stuff now
from a Layman's point of view I don't
think that is a good way of dealing with
that because what you do is you give
these people a glamor they perhaps don't
deserve or they don't deserve because
you effectively say their voice is so
dangerous they can't be you know they
must be silenced so that's an extremely
important point I just have a different
answer than what you're looking for I
think it's a matter of free speech and
if their risks in a world of free speech
that there could be people who are
dangerous because they create
instability in a system or because they
um lead people on a track
that may be impossible to reverse you
look at Hitler in 1930s Germany for
example it required all-out War to sort
of correct the attitudes and feelings
that Germans had about themselves
relative to the world at that time
so there's a risk when you have a free
Society for me as an educator the
antidote
is the education of how to listen to
people
so you you nip that in the bud from the
beginning
so if someone is speaking highly
charismatically about something that's
completely opposite what a mainstream
view is I will approach them with
skepticism
no matter how charismatic they are
because I will know
that only one in ten thousand of them
will ever be correct at this
and no we don't give courses on the 10
000 people that were wrong
no we don't that's a waste of
everybody's time
so
for some reason over recent years the
word establishment has become a bad word
I represent the establishment oh well
you must be wrong then no that's not how
it works it's not how it's ever worked
yeah so I'm not saying you should always
believe the establishment what I'm
saying is if you want to believe someone
who is against the establishment
you should do a little more homework
before you go that way and the homework
isn't only listening to what they are
telling you it's looking into the
establishment and find out why there's
an establishment view to begin with and
the establishment of you is not
from authorities on high no it's the
consensus of research conducted by
hard-working scientists in a lab whose
name you've never heard of
thank you
foreign